thank you I can be heard the
right well that's the title getting it
out there Python JavaScript and web
visualizations the main thrust is going
to be that I'm not saying if it's not on
the web it's not valuable something from
a visualization perspective but having
been caught with beautiful
visualizations that will require
installation pison or some library or
somewhere and then feeling that I should
get them onto the web and never really
finding the time and AH the threshold to
entry being what it is stuff just is out
there dead essentially no one will ever
see it and if you start from the premise
that you're going to stick it on the web
then you can just press a button one day
and everyone in the world will see what
you're up to which to me is a huge huge
advantage so this is sort of about
building up to that talk structure gonna
give a very brief and very partial
introduction to JavaScript from a
pythonista perspective mine then to
about Jason which is I'm sure all of you
know a data format and it's also pretty
much the glue between JavaScript and
Python I'm going to talk about how to
serve that Jason in a bespoke JSON data
the various ways you can do that a
couple of use cases and then summing up
first off get it out of the way this is
how the web should be you see something
cool you like you maybe want to emulate
you click on the view page source and
you see ah beautiful
it's not going to happen it's not going
to happen ever
it's so not going to happen for a very
long time if it does happen it will be
missing important libraries so the
important thing is just to face facts
you're not going to be coding in Python
on the browser anytime soon in a way
that is remotely like your experience of
coding in Python on the on the server so
it's lovely like the idea and I wish it
would happen but it's not it's going to
be like nuclear fusion it's always just
going to be a generation or so away so
right back in the real world javascript
is the only game in town that's it
if you're on the browser there's lots
and lots of things you'll probably hear
about but they all basically come down
to JavaScript
everything else is incredibly tacky are
not a good place for anyone any novice
to be starting and I'm kind of pitching
this novice wise I'm assuming kind of a
Python background who wants to sort of
spread into browser programming so then
the challenge is to make javascript play
nicely with your favorite back in tool
set of course in this case is Python and
to leverage path in pythons far superior
data crafting skills complement the good
news is there's nothing in JavaScript
that compares with the powerful Python
libraries nothing at all and there
probably won't be for a very long time
so they need each other basically but
the good news is javascript is getting
better and better much more powerful
never used to be and there are some
libraries there which quite frankly are
as good as anything in the Python world
thinking really prime area of say d3 but
there's some other stuff as well
d3 will crop up it's called data-driven
documents and it's a huge four hundred
pound gorilla of a library which I'm not
going to teach about today just mention
and so now a few personal observations
the picture sums it up really right oops
a JavaScript programming in JavaScript
is for anyone who sort of come from a
background where you would assume you
know fairly easy importation say of
modules they're working on that
server-side JavaScript has something
that sort of works but inevitably it
doesn't work on the browser so you end
up with this weird Shin that sort of
holds together but there's a religious
war there about what form that shouldn't
should take so basically it's confused
things like global by default are just
obviously evil if you just if you
declare a variable in JavaScript and
you're not careful then essentially it's
available available to the global
namespace in fact the whole idea of
namespaces is not enforced you have to
force yourself
the script was written in about two
weeks I think it was back in 1996 or
something it doesn't feel like a
language that was really thought about
deeply having so it's not as bad as
people might tell you but it really does
have rough edges um here's one the ugly
a certain basically you can't default
parameters how do you get them well you
end up doing this sort of thing a lot
looping even looping is much more
involved than it should be there is a
book by Michael Douglas Crockford who
created Jason called JavaScript the good
parts I'd recommend everybody to read
that it's quite short and and his his
may yes
his main his main idea is that
essentially if you if you enforce a few
kind of rough principles then you can
certainly save yourself a lot of pain in
in the in the future another thing to
mention this point really important if
you are programming JavaScript get
yourself a linter jslint is sort of the
standard that was written by crop foo
there's another one called J's hint
which is a more human crop it is a very
opinionated man and not everyone agrees
with with with his opinion at JavaScript
syntax but nevertheless if you get if
you've got Emacs or vim or anything
there'll be a linter that will basically
be parsing your code while you write and
everything that's wrong we'll just
appear in big roadblocks and that's
really really helpful it'll save you a
huge amount of trouble in the future and
there will be trouble I'm afraid right
so many stands choose from um there's
there is a culture the JavaScript which
I think is different to the culture of
Python Python having been in fight a
long time which means maybe the gloss
has worn off but not the gloss it's a
different word but it feels younger less
mature more kind of I was a script
kiddie and now in programming on your
server what could go wrong sort of thing
there are there elements of that and one
of the things the enthusiasm this
youthful enthusiasm means that a lot of
people just like to write libraries
they're not really interested in using
system ones are improving
they just want to write their own and
they do I've just I thought actually was
well well as watching Neil's talk
certainly Kurt a minute was so the
difference between a JavaScript
frameworks and and a bus is that the
JavaScript frameworks there's always
three coming along at once and as Pat
myself on the back for that but
basically all these all these ones they
come on I use one just down here called
angular I'm not released about there's
all sorts of ups now it's stable its I
like it enforces best practice it has a
lot of very good things going for it I'm
going to get into them now but I will
happily tell anybody afterwards why I
have opinions about this and why some of
these things I don't like and some them
I do but I chose shows angular I'm
sticking to its I really don't have to
try anymore so this kind of this kind of
visa into there's a word that crops up a
lot in JavaScript more than it doesn't I
mean it's obvious a programming word but
it old programmers kind of part of it a
taxonomy but it's the word awesome and
it's a word that kind of annoys me a bit
because I was saving that for when the
hand of God came down from the sky you
know or the birth of my first child or
whatever and then the hyperbolic
language gets to a point where
apparently you know a JavaScript
configuration file is awesome and I
don't know whether go linguistically
from that but it's particular
straighting when you find yourself so
middle-of-the-night your grunt config
file isn't working and you try and find
some help you go to google you do a
search and the first twenty links all
start or have somewhere in them the word
awesome because everything in the world
of javascript is awesome
so yes sorry i've been affected by that
and it really is not awesome it's lovely
in places but so you get this one this
is part of the youthful enthusiasm this
kind of emphasizes it this is not an
atypical thread this thread actually
occurred i it was a thread I was
interested in because I actually have
this problem so yeah does anyone know
how to set my grunt config file to
ignore term profiles in the watch
directory this is important by the way
especially use Emacs because it
generates
the temporary files um and the answer
was have you tried using gulp this was
the first answer they were few it down
that's we'll deal with it but this is
generally the feeling if you lie reason
work you just move on to the next one
that is better than the one before until
the next one but the goods that go it's
not all it's not all doing important to
emphasize you've got a hundred cent
insulation base there's an arms war
among the engine this is this is you
know you have got had orders of
magnitude imprudent in JavaScript in the
last few years we're talking about
thousands of times that's incredible
that hasn't happened anywhere it's now
faster than Python by some considerable
measure and you normalize the syntax
quirks you get use of them will go into
the CoffeeScript any very quick in a
minute it's exhilarating minutes the
flip side the West is exciting right now
and you have some increasingly powerful
visualization tools which are written by
proper programmers and are very solid
and which I can thoroughly recommend
they mean you can do amazing things on
the browser things that just wouldn't
been conceivable a few years ago so it's
worth sticking with the d3 video has has
decided to disappear doesn't matter
hey III as I'm working with a Mac for
the first time in then here's a year so
we'll go back to d3 and I'll just
describe it rather than to show you a
little video which didn't do a lot d3 is
what's called data-driven documents and
it's basically this humongous effort
that used to be a library proto vis that
we're a guy called Mike Bostock has
basically taken the absolute fundamental
tenets of graph drawing chart drawing
construction of visual visualize
visualizable data and and gone to
tasking ubiquitous PhD I use protists
maybe five six years ago and d3 has
grown from that and it's astonishingly
powerful flexible adaptable huge
learning was a huge learning curve
there's a big learning curve but unlike
lots and software it's actually worth
worth going through it
cross filter which you can generally use
in conjunction with d3 is you might see
here just to show you that JavaScript
has got sort of programming chops so to
speak battery may be running out okay
this is remove the batteries running out
no he's right
this is Crossville to cross filter was
librarian by Mike Bostock and friends
the idea was essentially to you've got
this huge data set of airline arrivals
departures from American airports and
the idea is be able to search all of
this in real time filtering the data by
various dimensions and searches and as
you can see by you're able to
essentially manipulate hundreds of
thousands of data points in real time
and that's all running using the
JavaScript engine so increasingly these
days the power requirements for gel for
complex visualizations are not are there
server-side JavaScript once again just
to emphasize there's nothing to compare
with the better Python libraries numpy
and Skippy absolutely nothing modularity
simple things like modularity the able
the ability to take modules and reuse
them code reuse is has not been nailed
down at all and as I said I think the
glory of Python is the libraries there
are a few edge cases where stuff like
nodejs would make a lot of sense to
somebody
massive asynchronous web traffic stuff
and I think in the way that if you've
got a hammer everything looks like a
nail for a lot of people basically run
with that and have ignored a few gaping
holes in the JavaScript ecosystem
certainly on the server copied script
you might hear about it's the Python
Ruby a syntactic sugar for various
reasons I tried it didn't like it
probably say new JavaScript beforehand
and
offer me anything particularly new the
main take-home is it's the debugging
it's a pre compiled there's a pre
compile phase and this means that we're
debugging you better have code mapping
working the browser and it's just
another thing to worry about personally
I would certainly wouldn't suggest if
anyone is starting JavaScript because
you might be able to understand the
debug so we've got a Python we've got
Jason we need Python on the data munging
and we need javascript to visualize it
the glue is Jason and Jason is
JavaScript object notation devised by
Crockford and this should make it a bit
more clear that's the sort of thing I
think for any pythonista that looks
pretty familiar workable you have
objects you have keyed objects you have
lists a fairly conventional data form
and using that you can communicate
between your Python server back-end and
your browser front-end and converting
between sort of from native Python
objects to Jason is not too difficult
stool in fact it's trigger of course
there's a JSON module and as you can see
it's pretty easy to use you load Jason
in you can do a load string which means
you load a addressing string which
you've hopefully protein formatted or
you can just load a file object and it
will convert that into a native Python
data structure so couldn't be more
convenient really service client this is
the sort of issue you're faced with so
these are these are the solutions to it
you're trying to get your Jason from
your web server to your browser you can
send a static file no flexibility it's
it's fast but you can't dynamically
change the data required you can't do
anything much you've got an API call
which is probably how most of the web
works
I was just restful if you don't restful
is I advise looking at up its
could save you a lot of headaches I
think restful api is worth the effort to
get right so basically here the web
browser will make a call back to the
server and request data according to a
restful URL the other option which is
getting used a lot more these days is
WebSockets
they're a bit esoteric even now but
there are some huge winds that you can
can get from using them and particularly
when you want to reuse existing engines
on the back end so if you've written
something in Python you already have a
visualization library say in Python and
you just want to swap out the Python
visualization library and stick in a new
spangly JavaScript version then
WebSockets is quite possibly a way to go
write lightweight servers one line
solution this is your development server
it couldn't be easier with Python that's
one line and that will basically if
you're developing you need to running a
server to negotiate your deal this is
your fault I'm going to kill you
afterwards
sorry I've said it now so I can't so
that is your lightweight server one
light line solution and the gotchas are
streaming video haha
and WebSockets can be problematic and in
that case you need something
not exactly heavyweight but that is a
lot more flexible and powerful flask is
my personal I guess the idea is having
tool sets or toolkits so you have kind
of a Best of Breed
I love flask because it's very
lightweight Jango is probably one you've
heard of it's huge it's great if you
want to build a full websites brilliant
if you want to build something where
you've got this minimal amount of code
to worry about you want something really
simple and pared down flask which is
built on works ugh is fantastic and
there you have your basic hello world
flask server which can be turned into
this is a very rudimentary little as you
can see restful api
cool Beijing see it's just a few lines
and then you have that running in route
and you can start playing around and
doing some interesting things on your
browser and making calls databases
people - that long go because it's bison
base we should buy since all the form of
JSON binary Jason I think and it's also
used in this meteor framework which
since she mirrors your [ __ ] database to
the browser which is lovely but the
meteor framework is working
the point is Python makes become Jason
so easy it's not really a big issue I
think and if you have problems with your
Jason form you can write a custom
serializer as an example at the bottom
which will deal with things data forms
that are not jace honorable easily you
can just you can encode and decode them
using a custom serialize which you
probably will have to do if you've use
anything more interesting than if you
use for example Python dates date times
that kind of stuff this is a just a use
case where I have pre-existing Python
code simulation code or an engine
anything that's or even out on our data
a data mining engine anything you can
imagine where you have had to hack
together a visualization front-end at
some point a GUI I think this is very
common scenario you've got your GUI it's
sitting there but it's on your desktop
and you want to share it with people and
you don't want to have them happen to
install stuff on their machine for all
sorts of reasons and so how can you make
it as easy as possible to make the
transfer and I guess for my purposes
nowadays I'm trying to use a kind of
iron rule which is if it will ever
conceivably need to be visually
displayed for anybody then it's got to
be on the browser and increasingly
there's no reason why that shouldn't be
the case it's very you can't now do and
just in terms of that the fact you can
distribute it to the world of the press
of button just that's just such a huge
advantage so
this was a little simulation I wrote for
the details aren't actually that
important but see so the idea is I mean
so just it doesn't matter what it is so
much but I had written a GUI a QT GUI
for this which had little robot and it
you can see its neural network there and
sort of you can say civil nervous system
and you can go in and just play with it
and everything was there except the
front end was all qtf ID and therefore I
couldn't show it when you want it it
didn't exist on the browser and so the
idea was just I set myself the task of
converting the bulk of it into just a
way to learn as much anything else into
into the web browser so you see this is
WebGL this is kind of 3d graphics and it
uses bootstrap and hangar and some other
stuff and this is sort of which i think
is a is becoming very easy to do you've
got your native GUI
you've got your engine if you've done if
you've been at all sensible you've
separated everything out you've got your
modular decomposition you can ask the
engine in my case a simulator for a
state you know the state of the robot's
nervous system at any one time the state
weight its position the position of its
limbs all that kind of stuff before
they've all been fed into a conventional
GUI and now all you've got to do is
interpose your flask server to pack the
data in a JSON form just JSON defy it
stick it out to your WebGL I'd say WebGL
anger and bootstrap is a pretty good
place to be starting if you'll be
looking at build kind of web consoles
and now you have it on web and that
means you can share it with the world
which ramiz er is a huge take on you can
also you know obviously a lot this is
the development purposes but what it
means is that because you built it in
you baked it in when that when and if
that time comes for you to start sharing
it you're not going to have as I have
millions occasions that threshold that
I'll get it done one of these days
you're not going to have that you're
you're in the zone
and that is a good thing
visualize in the way this is another
kind of I should mention all of the back
in there was done using Python and
siphon so someone who uses sizing so
visualizing webOS the old version I
possibly some English possibly because
just the weather occurs I wanted to play
around with some visualization and I
wanted to do some visualization using
maps so the idea was to go to the Met
Office and ask them for some data to see
if they had any historical data they're
not that generous has to be said I want
you to pay for most things these days
and they have a page this page where you
can go this is it pretty much and they
have the data that's been collected from
earth 30 or 40 or 50 stations around the
British Isles some of this started
collecting data in 1838 I think it's the
earliest one some of them stopped for
like 30 years and then came back on
again you can probably Majan what the
data files are like the data files are
interesting if you if you click
expectantly on one of these dots hoping
to see some kind of funky visualization
that's going to show you the weather
over time in that period you see well
it's exciting isn't it um it's obviously
not moving very fast but I I've slowed
it down so you can read it this data
format this data format was made up by
somebody in 1865 it's not tab but it's
tab separated whatever the the the are
called the null markers change arbitrary
other time they change the arbitrary
over space so different different
monitoring stations which is suddenly
use an asterisk to signify a null point
and others would use a hankie we're
talking about having to clean up the
data first to turn it into anything
allowing for the fact that it's just
horrible filthy Python makes this if not
a joy
it's just emphasizing the point I can't
imagine doing this in JavaScript I'll
pretty much any other language but in
Python it was more than feasible using
CSV and using
some other libraries to clean it up but
this is dirty dirty dirty data
thanks made office for making it so easy
for me so the idea was to turn that into
something like this
which okay so it's the idea you can kind
of click on different years and you can
see the we'd have some interesting blue
on the middle broth over the last few
months I think fortune assigns gets to a
2010 I'll have to see but yeah we'd have
an interesting signature now and right
okay
anyway it's lovely and really cool so
how do you go about turning the one into
the other and getting beautiful animated
weather that you didn't see clean
zoophiles pymongo a regex glove
beautiful no equipment in JavaScript
quite ins tailor-made for this kind of
stuff it makes it easy it's going to be
- in order to communicate with d3 and
get the graph information you need to
convert it to geo jason form there is of
course a geo jason library for python
and i wasn't expecting it to be anything
else it's easy to sort of emphasize it's
easy to get blase but there's always a
library in Python right which is
astonishing really for me for example
there was a the one of the problems was
converting these weird Met Office
coordinates which as I said started
sometime in 1880 into something that's a
conventional mapping program could use
and somebody had written one it's a
module and you know free to the world
it's out there on github and
I'm very appreciative I think this
possibly sums up for me or at least one
of these lines comes after me the power
of I guess Python skippy various other
things you've got all these arbitrary
data points on your on your map and you
want to produce an interpolated grid
that is nice and uniform
and an array it's kind of a bit of a
kind of head trip I mean I can kind of
think about how am I going to
interpolate module and that module has
interpolate 2d and you just feed in
you're pretty much a column of data and
outcomes interpolated grid which you can
then quiz for fashion longitude to send
your values to send through to d3
once again I couldn't be done in
JavaScript or at least I'd have had to
write a 4 or 500 line JavaScript I refer
myself
so in conclusion JavaScript is not just
a necessary evil the language has has
sort of crafty gnarly bits but it's not
actually as bad as you probably heard
it's also you very quickly as I
mentioned you normalize to the quirks
you just have to get used to doing
certain things till they become rote and
as mentioned a lintel will really help
you there it's actually getting some
first class libraries it's not just
horrible sort of sub jQuery well not the
jQuery is a horrible library but ah be
careful what I say I'll be lynched by
the Jay s boys all right but there have
been some kind of yeah they've been
slobbering pretty flaky in the past some
stuff out there now is getting good it's
getting good because the web is
everything right and it it needs to be
good and some people care enough now and
the tool sets are getting better it's
basically the perfect complement to
pythons data crunching and I honestly
think that separating the data crunching
abilities of Python and just I mean I've
used WX Pike and I've used qt I've used
them all and I've enjoyed them but at
the same time when it comes to sharing
them with anyone I'm lost I mean I I
just tend to put that to the back of the
priority list and it never happens so
yeah we can offload most visualizations
to the web and this is only get better
and easier
you've got opengl you've got a lot of
number crunching ability
and you've got d3 for example which is
really just first in class I think so
I played The Notebook and which I like I
this Vega you're not talking about Vegas
so much right I ignore all rogue maps I
just F it's got to be hold at least at
least six months although in JavaScript
six days is mature but I have to keep
reminding with Python it's like ten wise
men go up to the mountains before
anything happens you know and they
converse for six years and JavaScript
just happens like that so I bet I guess
in the Python ecosystem I'm generally
quite slow but that sounds great I mean
there is this thing called Vega which I
should have mentioned I think I did on
one slide a broken slide probably I just
um
there's a single Vega which in theory
will enable you to we not in theory I've
used it so it works you can actually
construct d3 graphs using Python it's
cool in my opinion you lose pretty much
everything that's great about d3 which
is the interactivity the other thing I
should have stressed is and the
difference the scene in that weather
chart we're talking about interactive
data which I'm at manipulating data
which I'm at drilling down we're talking
about playing with data getting into the
front visual cortex the ability to do
that is really important and a lot of
these widgets I don't know what that the
Python ones but love them will probably
end up being kind of not static charts
they'll certainly have a lot of limited
functionality okay but that's I guess
that's that's within the notebook sort
of yes okay cool that sounds pretty but
it I guess it's in it's a bit
specialized I mean it's great for Python
distance but it's a bit sorry
you just that was first demonstration
some kind of interactive crystallization
EVP group personally we actually ordered
a tone to the choir no I should have
mentioned which I was kind of in the
graph but think about WebSockets is it's
the create a two-way interface handshake
and it maintains that pipe it's the
basis it's a trick that has been used by
web gamers or web game designers so
basically you can have a server that's
generating data and the client is just
there's a two-way line of communication
so the client can request so technically
it's interactive it's interacted with
the server and the latencies are pretty
good so you can its gaming right so the
gaming boys are going to make sure that
it works Optima because they need low
latencies and I guess some of us would
be the beneficiaries of that but does it
sorry
do we have to have this challenge
imagine
something for some oh it's it's well
it's you set up a WebSocket in a flask
server or any serve you any whatever
server you're using you set up a web
socket and then the client has to know
to get the town to create that handshake
so yeah it's it's as hard as web sockets
which are not as hard as they might be
on WebSockets how's the weather plus
contained good
it has Jesus of gee I haven't I was just
looking for something easy and quick
they was using G event so I mean this is
kind of last thing flask isn't
technically a pretty good asynchronous
syrup sort of the box and it has certain
other quirks yeah blast blast work so
just download G event on it and it did
the job but that was yeah that's the
kind of hacky I did it for myself and if
I wanted to distribute it to other
people then I think I'd be looking for
something a bit more robust
I haven't used Sigma so much I mean I
haven't seen I haven't seen very much
stuff that that where you got the
feeling that JavaScript is just hitting
a ceiling of functionality I mean I
probably some Riesling a job I've been
doing where we were dealing with you
know a hundred and fifty thousand data
points Network in fact graph and and it
was fine
in fact you looked at the bottleneck and
it turned out drawing was the biggest
bottleneck it wasn't actually the math
it wasn't the day scrunching behind it
was rendering it on the screen was often
the problem and that could be an issue
with love this stuff but I don't feel
that the yeah I feel that JavaScript got
you sir thank you
CSS is kind of I guess not programming
it's kind of ukh with html5 you can do
some stuff but it you can't I don't even
know I mean CSS just it's just the style
she so it's just the gloss I mean CSS
and of itself obviously it's not a
language and so it's just just for
prettifying stuff my tip for CSS is I
like bootstrap which is this it's come
out of Twitter
yeah it's Twitter's kind of contribution
and it's I use it you have to if you're
doing kind of web design but you it's
not it's not I guess it's the boss is
the it's decoration so um yes you
my second choice is there a better
starboard that just start getting
philosophy
um possibly I mean one one thing you
could do is just as mention you could
serve as a static file just for deaf
initial just to get your head around it
you know so I mean you're going to have
a server somewhere if you're doing web
so you can if you just don't want to
worry about the API calls just serve a
static file with the data in it I mean a
lot of sites do that anyway if you if
you do what's called freezing your site
it's all static
so eventually end up with with data
files I would say a data file with your
day we just play toy data is a really
good way to get started
unfortunately I mean d3 as mentioned d3
which is something other recommends it
does have a high learning curve that's
going to be your that's going to be your
big learning everything else is pretty
simple by comparison the weather I could
I can't show you ah let's see the
weather was maybe 200 lines maybe 250
300 I mean that's the JavaScript the
Python which vennu ever sees that code I
will never get a job again but the
Python was was hacky especially hacking
the data and that ran into a few hundred
lines I guess and it's going to do